[Music]
you look at the cast of Doctor Strange
led by Benedict Cumberbatch and it is an
embarrassment of riches Benedict has got
the brains and the wit to know how to
play Doctor Strange and you are Wow
just one like Adele it's ugly it's
blowing the cost of this film I play
Christine Palmer er trauma dr. Stephen
and Cristina involved in this a
relationship and then as his life starts
to fall apart their relationship becomes
much much more strained you told me once
that losing my hands didn't have to be
the end there's other ways to save lives
and being able to work with all this
amazing actors just raises the stakes I
mean children looks incredible as the
ancient one she deals in magic in real
proper inner magic the mystic arts we
harness energy and shape realities I
want to do it in your place my character
is the intro to dr. strange entering
this this universe there's a strength to
him that is already Benedict wall-eyed
made a few films with now and it's weird
having two Benedict's in a movie once
involved in the training of young
disciples ever volume on this collection
should be stolen you'll be dead before
you ever left the compound
any late fees I should know about
maiming perhaps
[Music]
you